こんにちはーはじめしゃちょーでーす
みなさーんコップ使ってますでっしょ
あーっ('Д')
みなさんコップ使ってますでしょうか？
こうやって飲み物を飲むときに..
こうやってぴっぴって入れて
ごくごく
うめーつって飲むんですけどぉ
もぉー
このコップ、ネットで買ったんですけれども
スカンディノービア？っていう海外のメーカーが出してるらしいんですけども
もう冗談抜きでネットとか見ても
壊れないって書いてあるんですよ、マジで。
Amazonで買ったんですけども、Amazonで買う時も「割れないコップ」っていうタイトルで売ってて
うわうわうわうわうわうわ
盛ってる盛ってる～って思って買ってしまいました。
出た出た出た、もうほら、もうほら
割れないコップって書いてあります。
そして評価がなんと4.5！
高い…高い…！！評価が高い。
てことは、ほんとに割れないってこと！？
これなんか割れなそうですよね！
ただもう割れないって言うんだったら
よっぽど割れないんだろうな、ってことで
今回この割れないコップを
ぶっ壊してみようと思います！！( ｀ー´)ノ
O-Ho-Ho-Ho
みんな勘違いしないでくれ。今回はなんと！！
ここではなんと、この
割れないコップを造ったスカンディノービアさんに、
わざわざ許可をとって動画をとっております。
ご覧ください(*ﾉωﾉ)
はじめさんこんにちは。ご連絡ありがとうございます。メールの返事が遅くなり、申し訳ありません。確かに、弊社は日本でも販売しております。
弊社の製品をYouTubeチャンネルでテストしてくださるなら、とても光栄です。
今後の取り決めのため、おのさんも宛先に入れてあります。ご連絡を頂きましたこと、重ねて御礼申し上げます。
一応聞いてみたんですよ
だってさぁ…だってもの壊したら…(察して…)
これで怒る人がいたらマジほんとにあのー
作った人の立場にもなれ！
ってことになりますからね
私はこう、色々と実験をしてみたいです！っていう
このコップが強すぎて壊れないって言ってるんだったら
落としてみたり、なんか色々して
壊したいんですけど
テストしたいんですけど良いですか？って言ったら
「宜しくお願いします」ということでございました
ので、壊していきまーす！
あっあっあっあっあっあーっ!!あーっ!!あああああああっ!!!
わっわっわっわっ
うわっあっあっ
やばっ
コップ「くらえ！」
いでえええああああああああ!!
はあああ！！
おわ～
うええ
どわあああああ！！
いきます！
所沢「いてぇ！なにすんだよ！」
やったか？
うーわ
うえええええ...
コップ「戻りまーす」
は！
は！あ...
コップ「うわああああああ！！」
あれ？
山岸めぐみ「痛い！」
こわいっ!!
なあ焦げ臭い
わっ
はっはっはっはっはっ
すげぇ
あつううううう!!!
車「コップ弾発射！！」
^^
コップ「あつい！」
コップ「あつい！！！やめろ！！！」
コップ「やっと終わった...」
あっ！
まいりましたぁぁぁぁ